okay so let's let's start some buzzword
in this title I look power not buzzword
really useful embedded intelligence
buzzword I agree emerging devices useful
for scaling and new design paradigms
using neuromorphic architectures so I'll
try to show you today how we've been
able to address the low power circuit
challenges so different applications and
really addressing the architecture the
design and the device level if you look
at this tag here we have been able
through years to address different
architectures for the cloud which is
more multicores multi CPUs edgehog so
here yet we'll start to have some power
challenges and then n devices so n
devices we know that we have a lot of
power challenges why because we want to
have autonomy in any case in this tag we
have some thermal issues and we are all
this is limiting a lot the performances
of the circuit so not only the power but
also the thing that we have is that we
have a lot of variations at each layer
here limiting the overall circuit
performance is what does it mean it
means that if we want to push the
circuit performances at any time we have
some limitations because we have a lot
of variation in mitts it means that we
are never expecting the real
performances that we have in our circuit
in the end so it's really important to
consider low power in terms of energy
efficiency it means that whatever is the
performance that you want to target you
still want to have the minimum power
according to the variations limiting
your your your application in your
architecture so for this something
really interesting and kind of intuitive
would be to have systems that are really
adaptive so adaptive means that systems
are flexible adaptive to what is
happening in the circuit in the
application in the architecture and able
to provide the optimal performances in a
circuit for this you need to take into
account all the level of attracts
abstractions it means that from
application down to the technology you
need to bring adaptivity and flexibility
to the circuit
it means that you do not want to have a
single technology with one performance
maybe you want to have many different
performances available you don't want to
target one point of operation but maybe
a range of operation depending on the
application so for this what you want is
high energy efficiency it means that you
don't want to necessarily push the speed
or reduce power but for a certain speed
you want to have the minimum power of
course ideally you would like to have
this in an automatic way dynamically of
course because these variations are
happening dynamically during the
computation so it can be kind of static
but most of the time if you can modify
and adapt your system dynamically you
have a huge gain in energy of course
this is what we can call Auto adaptive
circuits it's the optimal way to do it
we need to consider that variations are
not only technology but also environment
it means that when you are looking at
end devices you can be in very
unpredictable environments for example
if you are recovering the energy from
the environment then things can change a
lot and you are maybe not recovering the
energy that is expected and of course if
we push this paradigm to its natural I
would say natural implementation
intelligence is the more adaptive thing
that we can have because human beings
are really adaptive by nature so I think
that you are already adaptive to your
environment to your intrinsic variations
and this is automatic and it's kind of
high energy efficient so this is what
I'm pushing when I say embedded
intelligence is ready for going more
adaptive more flexible so my talk today
will address different ways of adding
more adaptivity and flexibility into
architecture and design the first is we
can look at architecture and for
different applications or multi cores
and IOT devices today I will more
address multi course how can we bring
more flexibility to these architectures
in the way to have more energy
efficiency it's always the objective of
course at the moment so we
the more slow and the scaling the
multicores will have more and more
variations and adaptivity will have some
limitations then we can go to more
interesting architecture using 3d
devices and I'll show you how we can
have more flexibility they're using
interesting network on ships and more
architecture that our memory centric
I'll show you how we can increase the
performance there and the third part of
the talk is ready dedicated to embedded
intelligence so what does it mean to get
inspiration so I don't want to mimic the
brain but I'd like to get some
inspiration from the brain to have
adaptive circuits and using new devices
the first part is dealing with
architecture and design the first thing
really important today is when you look
at the architecture if you want to run
the full multi-core system at the same
voltage and frequency at the same speed
then you have a lot of issues the first
is it's difficult to of course to
distribute the clock the other thing is
if you consider that you have some
variability in your circuit probably one
core is not functional at the same speed
and power from another core so you need
to consider a partitioning of the
architecture where you could have cores
running a different speed
but that at that point when you consider
cores that have speed a different speed
then you need to consider how these
cores are communicating together and how
to do that in the best way so why not
very interesting architecture for that
is what we call globally asynchronous
and locally synchronous architecture so
what does it mean it means that here you
have all these islands in different
colors that are running at their own
speed it means that in case of
variability of power or power management
you could modify the voltage and the
frequency of these islands separately
and independently from another then you
need to reconsider to consider the
synchronization between the cores and
here what you can have is have a system
that is globally asynchronous when you
resynchronize with the communication and
locally synchros this is what we call
the gas we have different way to
implement this so one
way is to use asynchronous design so why
I think ruse designed there for the
communication I mean not for the core
why I think Rose design is interesting
there so you have this view here which
is showing been well the robustness of
an asynchronous circuits to variations
so in a synchronous circuit you have
these people giving the bucket to the
neighbor at each tick of the clock okay
so it's working very well as long as
nothing is happening and as long as you
have enough time to give the bucket to
the neighbor it the slack time in an
asynchronous circuits it's this line
here what you have is that the protocol
for communicating data is based on and
shake it means that you communicate the
data the bucket here to the neighbor
only when the day bar is ready to
receive it
so it works very well whatever is the
variation so why whatever is the
variation because you can think that one
guy here in the line is encountering a
variation I don't know why a fly or
something and then is not able to get
the bucket then the neighbor will wait
will wait as long as this person is able
to get the bucket so it means that
whatever is the variation the circuit
will always be functional at the cost
sometimes of some more delays but in
terms of rubbish Ness it's very
interesting when you think about
different islands communicating together
at different frequencies then you can
Rick synchronize very easily so when we
started well the community started on
globally async routes and locally
synchronous circuits the first very
interesting things for reducing power
was the frequency scaling because here
naturally you can have different islands
running a different frequency and it's
just really easy and natural to have the
communication together with the
asynchronous system so the first
implementation we had was first to
design this asynchronous network on chip
bringing the robustness to the
synchronization into the network and
chip itself so it's kind of really
simple here you have a 2d mesh structure
the network on chip and the node of the
network and chip are performing all the
in asynchronous communication and what
we have here in terms of design
is what we call quasi delay insensitive
so it means that whatever is the
whatever is the variation due to voltage
surprised changes in temperature
changing the circuit is always
functional there is one basis impetuses
that we insure by constriction when we
design the circuit we have specific
encoding and protocol this is for the
handshake so you remember that we don't
have clock ticks we have this n check
and this we first demonstrated it some
times ago we already have a lot of
generation of it and what is very
interesting is when you go from one
technology to another whereas in
synchronous circuit it takes time is
difficult here it was always functional
so sometimes not always optimal in terms
of performances but it's very
interesting to see that here in Twista
cailli you have the rubber sness for the
variations and for porting to different
technologies so in this first circuit
that is shown here naturally we had 24
clock domains corresponding to 24 IP is
running at 24 different frequencies and
we were resynchronizing the data from
one court to another just by using this
asynchronous network on chip so here at
that time it was 130 we had about less
than 20% dynamic power but already it's
an interesting number if you consider a
multi quorum so one more step now so we
have seen how to manage the voltage the
frequency we also we have also been able
to manage the voltage of each Island
because remember when you are doing
frequency scaling you reduce the dynamic
power but then you need to go through
voltage scaling to reduce the dynamic
power quadratically and the leakage
power as well so if you consider an
architecture now doing what we call
devfs so dynamic voltage and frequency
scaling you have the core here you
modify the voltage and you modify the
frequency ok it works very well
everything here is synchronized by the
asynchronous Network on chip or in
another in another frequency but in a
gals way the
that if you consider advanced
technologies it's really difficult to
set this voltage and frequency points
because you you can set it but during
computation you will have some voltage
drops you will have temperature
variations that are local to the chip
you don't have a lot of process
variation except for aging but you need
to manage what we call the Pvt
variations and this is not easy just to
set the voltage and frequency point
because you remember to reach this this
high energy point I energy efficiency
point and we need to set these two
parameters according to what is
happening in the core so this is what we
call adaptive voltage and frequency
scaling so what does it mean it means
that in addition to the actuators that
you have to modify the performance of
your circuit that are here the voltage
supply and the frequency you need to add
some sensors inside the circuit giving
you an information of what is happening
in the circuit so interestingly when we
started all this so we had in mind to to
have some sensors so usually what a
digital designer do when she or he wants
to have a good sensors are going to
analog designers and then provide
wonderful temperature sensors which is
twice the size of the core ok great so
we have the same issues when we wanted
to have local frequency generators
because we went to book people doing RF
and they were providing a wonderful PLL
which was maybe 10 times the size of the
core here okay so we've been able to go
finer so the interesting idea here that
we don't need to know the absolute
temperature we don't need to do the
absolute value of the voltage what we
need to know is that these values values
are changing so very simple sensors
giving you a dynamic information of what
is happening in the core is really
enough then when you have this
information you need to extract the real
information
what's the Pvt information and how is it
changing and then you have a local loop
that is adjusting the voltage and the
frequency
according to this information of the
sensor so the main target is your
application but according to this
information there probably you can
monitor the voltage and frequency to
reach this high energy efficiency okay
we don't want to reduce the voltage for
reducing the voltage we want to reduce
the voltage according to a target
frequency which is usually constrained
by the by the application so we have DFS
just modifying the frequency of each
course it having a Gulf architecture
helps a lot to have this then we move to
devfs that I didn't show here for a
question of time but here it means that
you modify the voltage and the frequency
of each score and you still have this
girl's architecture then you go to add
activity and to limit the impact of the
variations we go to a VF s which is
adaptive voltage and frequency scaling
architecture so we modify the voltage
and frequency according to interesting
PBT variations and dynamically so really
important is this dynamically okay so at
this step we already had some interest
in the architectures that are used a lot
today by many multi-core processors so
what is mainly do today when you have a
very large multi-core running at I don't
know 3 5 4 gigs they need to manage the
voltage storm that they have at the
starting so usually this is really done
for that to manage the starting point
but then during operation you still have
some information to to track and mainly
the voltage groups are something really
important to track so we know we do not
only have sensors that are just giving a
pivot information we also have some
information that I inside the critical
path of the circuit using some kind of
raisers so it's what we call timing
fault sensors but here we don't want to
detect a fault we want to anticipate the
fault so remember we are in an adaptive
system and this is what is difficult
because you need then to detect a
voltage droop in less than two cycles
and then being able to feedback the
information to improve the performances
so something interesting so what is
important is that I'd see a lady we have
a design and architectural division but
historically the technology division is
really leading our research so for years
we have been pushed to go to more new
technologies and also to use a BSI which
has been developed originally by Letty
and when we were thinking about all
these adaptive things people were coming
with MDS so as a whole look we have
something very interesting in MDS why we
have this bag buyers that is just
available because you are able to bias
the back pain of the transistor here and
what it brings is if you increase this
back bias you can go either to very high
VT transistors it means that you can
lower the leakage you can go to very
small VT transistors it means that you
can higher the speed increase the speed
and if you think about this adaptive
systems compared to what we have in
classical bulk this is limited by the
diodes that you have in bulk here you
can go so theoretically you can go to
plus minus 3 volts in practice we have
been able to go to 1.8 volts and in
reality plus 1 1 volt is already
something ready affordable for leakage
and already boosting a lot the
performances so if we look now at our
adaptive architecture what does it mean
it means that here we have a new
actuator and this actuator is the back
bias actuator it's not in the same
dynamics then the voltage supply and the
frequency because when you modify the
back plane of your architecture you need
to charge all the capacitance and of the
back plane and it takes time so it's
another point of optimization but really
clearly it helps to find a new way of
adapting circuit and it's extremely
efficient at low voltage which is really
interesting because usually we want to
go low voltage because we know that it
saves power but a low voltage we are
rarely limited in terms of frequency so
this is what we have
strated here with the DSP 32-bit DSPs
already simple what is first interesting
to see in this figure here is that we
are able to run at low voltage at very
high frequency secondly what is
interesting to see here is that if you
consider the adaptive scheme here you
have if you fix the frequency which is
usually what you want you can have a
gain up to 20% when you modify the back
bias
so the different colors here are the
different values of the back bias of
course it will be at the cost of the
leakage or it will be at the cost of the
speed it depends if here your target is
to have a fixed energy budget which is
sometimes the case in some applications
then you are able to increase a lot the
frequency and it's really efficient
mainly at low voltage not not sub
threshold but near threshold voltage or
even know where the nominal voltage so
this brings a very high flexibility so I
think here I showed you how we can bring
more flexibilities to classical
architectures that are digital
architectures with multi-core so
bringing new actuators with new
technologies so it means that scaling
will bring you will give you a lot of
variability we know how to manage it at
design an architectural level technology
like idea so I can bring you one more
way to adapt your circuit but there are
some limitations here we are now so if
you want to push more the performance
the idea is to use 3d architectures so
what kind of 3d technologies do we have
today so we have the kind of 3d
technology that is die on die what you
called through-silicon vias or TSVs
and the pitch that we can fabricate with
that so when I say with not only CL 80
people are providing that already in
fabrication it's around the pitch of 20
micrometer okay it means that if you
want to stack dies on dies its kind of
visible but the grain of stacking is
quite coarse if you move now to more
dense interconnect
you can go to ibrid bunging which is
mainly done today by copper to copper
and here you can see that the pitch that
is visible is two to five we have even
demonstrated now some hybrid bonding
with one micrometer pitch so in terms of
interconnect density it's already quite
high so here you can either have wafer
on wafer or dye on wafer so already here
you are increasing the number of
interconnect so in terms of partitioning
of Architecture it brings you something
new it means that maybe a partitioning
inside the core so block per block or
copper block or SRAM on logic is
something that is more feasible and if
we push the density more if we push the
density we can go even to what we call
so monolithic 3d sequential 3d so there
are many many different names for that
actually we call it cool cube because
it's a it's a cold process to to
fabricate it and here when you look at
the pitch it's really small it's not dot
one micrometer it's meant that
potentially you could take a transistor
on the top of another transistor so okay
this is technology it's great so you can
see here that the story of what I call
3d stack at C le T is not starting today
so it started some times ago already we
have always tried to have some companies
helping us in going this way and going
3d and if you look at this slide that I
will not detail today what is
interesting is that after all these
years we've been able now to demonstrate
some real circuit in architecture so
what is very important when with that
kind of a flow is that usually people
are providing very interesting
technologies another time they come and
say oh we have a wonderful 3d technology
and you can have this pitch and okay
what are you doing with that so as
designers and architects usually people
what they do is all we have a 2d design
let's put it in 3d most of the time you
have no gain it's really clear and as
when we were designing synchronous
circuits people came in to all you
should design that in a synchronous okay
but
versus async loose no gain but if you
think about the architecture and the
functionality okay I think Rose can help
in gals for example and here the same
idea
the idea is you have more interconnects
the interconnect is more than so what
does it mean in terms of architecture it
means that each time in your
architecture your limitation is the
interconnect then you can start thinking
3d so for more flexibility if we want to
have more interconnects more control
more data communication thinking 3d can
be already a good starting point so I'll
show you what we have so still in mind
flexible architecture so I will not
review all what we did in 3d and what
all what is done but still thinking
flexibility something we demonstrated
that is really interesting so you
remember this globally asynchronous and
locally synchronous architecture and we
have this asynchronous interconnect so
in 2d it's really convenient because we
no need to distribute the clock on the
full chip we just distribute the
different IPS and something interesting
happening when we started to do the 3d
so people came with the technology you
have different stacks it's wonderful and
the first question we we we had was Wow
but how can we communicate between the
top tier and the bottom tier okay we
have kind of same technologies but then
we need to community we'd have no ideas
about the performance of the TSV
themselves so something quite natural
was to think about using this
asynchronous work on chip so you
remember we have the handshake at the
interface and the I'm shake can be
performed in the protocol using the 3d
and whatever is the delay that you have
due to this TSV or if the TSB is really
bad then you still have the
functionality of the communication
between the top tier and the bottom tier
something really interesting that is
shown here so here is the asynchronous
nug that we had in 2d we put it in
sweetie and on the top of it we have
some processors so it's really multi
course under fabrication now we have
even 90s
scores that are fabricated and stacked
on the top of them something interesting
is this curve here so what we've shown
here is we have different links in the
network on chip we have tracked
different links with redundancy with
tests no tests and so on but what is
more interesting is that we changed the
temperature from the top tier to the
bottom tier so it means that we mimic a
large variation but in reality we also
have some thermal issues at the
interface so it's really something that
is real and automatically without any
control the data throughput of the
network and chip is modified according
to the temperature changing so this is
ready something that is showing just
flexibility stacking and natural
adaptivity to what is happening in a 3d
stack so now if we are going more depth
I would say so something interesting is
when you talk about 3d some people you
can always talk to our image tensor
designers for them it's really
convenient to build everything in 3d
first it's natural because usually they
have the sensor and the electronic that
is already stacked and they always think
about putting more computing in the in
the pixels in the columns and so on so
these people are always very attracted
by these 3d technologies something
interesting is here again
people started thinking about imagers in
3d but just by having the 2d imager and
providing it in 3d so what happens in
this case so when you have any major you
compute all of the columns and then you
get the information from the columns and
in 3d you compute the columns and you
process the information in the bottom
but finally the frame rate per second is
still the same compared to 2d except
that okay you have the SRAM on the top
or you have the computation the top so
in terms of area it's more interesting
but if when you want to think 3d and
parallel the idea would be to directly
compute the information
from the pixel or from a group of pixel
directly in the bottom so this is what
we did in this circuit that will be
presented and demonstrated destroyed
VLSI symposium so in June if you want to
come in Hawaii so it's a two layer 3d
stack psi so backside illuminated region
ship so what does it mean vision chip it
means that you have the sensor and you
have the computation so something really
important to see and that you will see
here that you have all the array here
and for each macro pixel so we call it
macro pixel we have some computation on
the bottom something interesting here is
that we do not only have the information
from the pixel to the computation but we
also have some feedback information to
control the electronic around the pixel
so it means that on the top we have
pixel ADC and the computation on the
bottom so what does it bring so
naturally if you have something that is
fully pro the frame rate per second is
not limited it means that here we've
been able to obtain 5000 frame per
second some people are getting this also
but what they do it that they are
reducing the resolution of the ADC so
it's kind of fake here we never reduce
the the the ADC resolution and we still
get there - per second this is exactly
what we want when we are doing some
parallel computation with a high density
interconnect so I like to show this
figure because they always have very
nice picture in the 3d technologies so
here you see the image and the stack so
here you have the photo diodes of course
we need the photo diodes to backside
eliminate the the chip and here you can
see the vias the wire so the the copper
copper bonding and on the bottom we have
all the mixed signal designs going there
and all the 3d connectivity so an
important figure that you need to have
here is the number of signals and the
number of interconnection that you have
so here it's more that than 6000 signals
which is a very high
so imagine in 2d how to be able ready to
to route all these and all these wires
here it's kind of natural because you
have the 3d stack so improving the
Prolog computation using all the wires
and increasing the frame per second this
is exactly what we would expect from a
3d architecture so then if we are going
to really dense technologies now so what
we call sweetie monolithic so we are
able to have a stack transistor on
transistor so it's ready fine-grain so
yes as a designer point of view it's
kind of difficult to to really know what
the benefit will be to have a so dense
interconnect because already with the
ibrid copper 2 cutter people are really
interested but finally if you want to
push the architecture you have more
interconnect and to think about the
computing as something which is close to
the memory or even inside the memory
this very dense interconnect will give
you all the information close to the
computation and this is what we will
explore so here again the same picture
too just to tell you that the 3d
monolithic is yet not something new at
letting you see that the picture here is
more dense that's what we had for the 3d
stack of course it's less mature
technology but yet if you look at here
we start to have some first circuits and
we already have some tape out running so
we'll be able to demonstrate some
architectures using very high density 3d
but of course it takes time it's not 8
years it's still 2 layers
of course we would like to have 7 10 8
layers but the technology yet is not
made sure but we can think about very
nice perspectives for that kind of
architectures so one first perspective
that we think about is what we call
memory centric architectures so this we
are working in collaboration with
Stanford and the idea is ready to use
this high density interconnect to go
really close to the memory
to the computing and the memory
something fully parallel it's really
something that we go yeah memory centric
architecture which is different
architecture that we used to use there
are different things that we are
exploring here so first is you know that
now we can have access to the
computation inside the memory this is
what we called in memory computing it
can have some benefit to design this in
memory computing in 3d this is what we
are currently exploring at architectural
level of course the idea is then to
extend this capacity that we have inside
the memory and 3d extended to more
computation using maybe some simple
operation
instruction sense there and why you and
IBM trying to do so yeah I see you have
different ways to do it so you can have
bitwise okay so bitwise it is or men
I'll end absorbs then it's really useful
for kind of security applications if you
want to have multiplications you need to
go to more analog arrays with quicker
flows okay but in theory you could have
access to all the arithmetic that is
available in a memory then of course you
need to program it and you need to think
about the architecture using the memory
as the computation so of course in terms
of programming it's something different
that you need to handle the idea here is
ready to show because what we discuss a
lot is ok we have this computation in
nyam C but very good digital designers
with a good technology will maybe do
something that is better or even a more
interesting but when you go 3d things
are changing because maybe you can get
the benefit of both you can get the
benefit of 3d having the memory close to
the computation and you can maybe get
the benefit of the computation inside
the memory so I don't have the answer
yet but this is really new architectures
that we are looking at actually I be
actually trying to sell some machines to
us a few dozen customers in the late 80s
different Greiner of stacking okay so
here we are not talking about HBM or
whatever it's different grain of
stacking okay IBM would work with no
turd on Peter Croce on the processor
memory stuff and they apparently built
some number of machines but also they
did the separate direction within what
you using the Rio at six thousand I'm
you know 6000 series CPUs well - it's a
matter of granular and you know also the
the the name processing in memory has
been used for so many things
usually what we say is processing in
memory is more near near memory
computing and HBM and so on this is
usually what we used to say for
processing in memory what we call in
memory computing is really the memory
able to perform some computation and
then memory centric architecture is we
have the computation really close to the
memories of in all these landscape I
would say there are so many
contributions that are interesting to to
get into to to see how 3d cad helped for
that so this is what we are currently
exploring so just to give you the full
picture which is really something that
we are just exploring now the idea would
be to be able to stack some computing
and some in-memory computing on the top
of it and why not
inserting some non-volatile features we
could help to have more density but also
could help to have different
applications in that kind of objects so
I've been through these different 3d
technologies and how it can bring more
flexibility more performances and how we
can think 3d when we think about
architecture something really important
now also is to if we think about this
really fine drain we can think about the
way the brain is constructed and you
know that the brain is by nature formed
by 3d cortical column and it's the basis
of learning so why wouldn't we wouldn't
we take advantage of this 3d with a very
high interconnect to try to have more
performances in learning so we are not
there yet but it's kind of inspiration
that we try to get
something else is thinking about more
than two stacks we could think about
image sensors that are ready be able to
stack some image sensor analog
computation and then memory and then
computing so here ready you think about
the full stack and all the computation
in the analog in the different stacks
and the performance will be already
improved so I've been through
architecture and design 3d architectures
try to think 3d to maybe have more
performances more functionality in new
applications and I'll try to go now to
what I call embedded intelligence which
I think is of course the optimal way of
doing some adaptive circuits I will
mainly focus on spiking circuits and new
devices so the reason for that so I know
that there are a lot of discussions on
spiking neural networks and so on but
once you want to leak link new devices
and and neural networks linking new
devices with spiking is kind of
something which is really optimal
because if you try to mimic the the the
spiking in a synapse with an ox Ram it's
exactly the way it works in the brain
and also you will see that 3d is really
convenient to interconnect all the
spikes coming from the sensors with the
computing so here the idea is not to
mimic the brain again
the edges to get inspiration from the
brain for more flexibility because if
you think about learning it's the way we
ourself we adapt the environment because
we learn and once we learn we know how
to adapt to any variations that can
happen it's interesting to think about
embedded learning because what we want
to show you remember this high energy
efficiency I'm still in the low power
landscape here it's difficult to bring
big neural networks to end devices it
consumes a lot of power you can do
training and inference but in reality we
really need to provide that to end
devices because we need to have this
learning it can be of many different
sorts it's not necessarily neural
network
it can be reinforcement learning but in
any case it will give you some
contextual information it's a scheme
that is fully even driven so you
remember that we have a lot of
experience on a synchronous circuit so
this even driven scheme is really
convenient to asynchronous circuits it's
all tournament to be to have some ember
learning and Low Energy so this is
really what we would like to get from
the learning so after this slide I have
a movie which is merging all the
technology which is merging all the
technology with the which is merging all
the technology with what we can do with
neuromorphic and from this movie I will
have three key messages but I can run
the movie firsts it works so - located
in Grenoble France inspired by the human
brain whose computing efficiency and
low-power performance still remain
unmatched
letti is developing novel neuromorphic
systems using optimized emerging CMOS
technologies the brain and spinal cord
form the central nervous system the
brain processes and coordinates the
body's activities using information from
the sensory receptors neuro imaging has
revealed a multi-layered brain structure
with an outer reconfigurable cortex area
and subcortical hard wired core the
cortex is composed of a very big number
of large-scale neural networks arranged
hierarchically in horizontal layers and
vertical columns having dense modules
and sparse overall connectivity neurons
are the elementary building blocks of
neural networks they communicate by way
of action potentials or spikes which
propagate along axons and accumulate in
specialized regions called synapses
transmission across the synaptic gap is
accomplished by chemical messengers
called neurotransmitters connections
between neurons are altered in response
to a stimulus the persistence of these
alterations is the biological basis of
humour
memory learning requires synaptic
plasticity which refers to the capacity
of change in the synapses structure
inspired by neuroscience and the
functional principles of the human brain
Letty scientists are developing
innovative low-power systems by
implementing optimized special purpose
hardware fabricated on three hundred
millimeter waivers novel emerging
technologies are being used for the
synthesis of smart systems artificial
neurons are being manufactured using
specialized CMOS circuits based on fully
depleted SOI technologies with a mixed
signal design approach FD SOI
technologies pioneered by Letty have
proven to be suitable for ultra low
power design non-volatile resistive
memories are promising components to
simulate synaptic behavior Letty is
developing resistive random access
memories such as phase change memories
conductive bridge memories and vertical
oxide based memories the variation of
their resistive state enables
information storage these technologies
offer non volatility precise conductance
modulation and high density of
integration needed to model synaptic
behavior based on the columnar
organization of the brain cortex Letty
is integrating F de SOI circuits and
resistive memories monolithically using
an extremely dense 3d integration
technology called cool/cute active
device layers are stacked sequentially
using very low thermal budgets this
makes it possible to obtain very small
3d contact pitches of the order of 100
nano meters within and between the
different tiers less dense 3d
integration is also possible with more
than more technologies such as
through-silicon vias coupled with hybrid
bonding techniques these allow for high
parallelism and energy efficient
computing the use of photonic wave
guides to connect networks across long
distances offers high speeds high
bandwidth and low crosstalk the central
nervous system is connected to our
senses see hearing touching tasting and
smelling and to our emotions thoughts
and
Maree similarly extremely low-power
context-aware multi module platforms
with spiked based neural networks can be
directly interfaced to bio inspired
event-driven sensors for image audio
tactile and chemical sensing brain
inspired hardware coupled to new
computing paradigms will exploit the
full potential of new disruptive
technologies and address the enduring
power efficiency issues of traditional
computing architectures distributed
intelligence will span the whole IOT
network sustaining our hyper connected
society and benefiting individuals
worldwide
[Music]
okay so three key messages from my
perspective of course there are many key
message is their business the first one
is if you look at the brain the
computation is fully distributed clearly
you don't have access to a mass memory
you get the weights and so on it's fully
distributed everything is in the synapse
and in the neurons during the
computation and probably it brings a lot
of efficiency power efficiency I don't
say in low energy but energy efficiency
second thing is everything is working
with spikes and probably this brings
also very low energy providing data with
bikes and interval between the spikes
give the information all the sensors
that we are that we have are providing
spice through the brain so it means that
our vision sensor is not at all a
chimera providing an image our vision
sense sensor is providing spikes and
then the brain is able to recover all
the spikes and fabricate the image third
message is by construction the brain is
really interconnected and the more you
learn the more interconnections you have
and this is ready done by 3d cortical
columns that you can find mostly
everywhere in the brain and this column
are really the basis of the learning so
the idea is to see how we can use this
from the brain and use new emerging
technologies to see if we can bring some
more intelligence in the IOT device so
the idea is low power efficiency of
course so the first thing that we are
working on our resistive ram so you've
seen in the movie that we have many
different resistive Ram so I won't go
through the details of the technology
here but the idea is to think that we
can use these technologies as synapses
it's it can have exactly exactly the
same function as a synapse so this is
what we are currently demonstrating here
so we still do
have the chip but what we did here is to
build the synapses as acts from and then
have some computation so it's a it's a
very small application here but the idea
are ready to use the spike at the input
and to perform some simple application
ready showing that we can build the
synapses with the extremes second thing
that is really interesting is that today
a lot of sensors that are claiming to be
low power it's not always true but we
can it's still a good start are
providing some spikes it means that for
example on an image sensor instead of
providing the image when you just have a
changing in the image sensor you provide
a spike where the pixel has changed if
you think about tactile sensors they are
providing spikes if you think about
artificial retinas they are providing
spikes there are many sensors today that
are providing space cochlear also but
what people do is that they have the
spikes most of the time the information
is cutted in the interval time interval
between the spikes so what people do is
that they are doing time to digital
converters and then they are able to
compute all the information in digital
with classical DSP of course it has a
cost and here again is just thinking
about okay how can I do computation I
have a good digital DSP okay let's put
around everything to convert to
something that is interesting for me but
this has a cost so the idea is that we
have designed a DSP that is just using
the input spikes or using the precise
timing between the spikes and here we
are able to pair from a lot of operation
so more than a classical DSP because by
construction when we reassemble the
different neurons and the different
types of synapses together we are able
to perform a lot of reparation nonlinear
operation or whatever and by nature this
DSP is
approximate it means that when you want
to reduce the number of bits then
naturally the power scales it means that
now we can interface directly a sensor
with a DSP and this DSP is directly
computing spikes so be careful here it's
not a question of neural network okay we
are using neurons to compute the spikes
but to perform computation like a DSP so
we already have some good results even
if the the Pico jodhpur synaptic even
could be lower but we really showed the
functionality of an audio processing it
means that we have a data set coming
from eth at Zurich and they provide all
the information from an artificial
cochlea and we have been able to process
all the information directly from the
spikes and at very low cost compared to
a GDC plus a DSP okay so now if we move
to more I to the future I would say so I
will just show you two works in progress
just to show you the objective and what
we are targeting and it will be the end
of my talk so first is we try to work on
3d cortical columns so we are not
started yet really but we'll start with
a Stanford student and some people
working at lady so the idea here is if
you look at the the cortical columns in
the cortex they are clearly 3d so if you
look here you have different stacks what
is really interesting is that with a
compared a new baby born and I don't
know it's 2 years or more the more you
learn the more the interconnections you
have but not only that the more you
learn the more the function of the
neurons in the different layers are
changing so it means that if you can
think about having more interconnections
being able to reconfigure the types of
neurons between the layers probably you
will improve a lot the way you can learn
in a circuit of course at this step here
what we will just consider is trying to
improve the so we we have some sensors
providing some spikes and these spikes
are computed by the court
so we will first try to look at the
first level here trying to interconnect
all the spikes to the first neurons and
see what we can have already so it's the
first step and we'll try to tape out
this this circuit at the end of the year
something else if we want to go to more
than 3d we are working on spiking vision
system so here again the idea is to have
an imager
that is a spiking sensor another layer
which is able to do the mixed signal
processing directly using the spikes or
maybe maybe just translating the spikes
into a digital system then providing all
the memory that we need and all the
computation for this we need a lot of
layers so this is what we are trying to
to manage now and of course on the top
of it we need para management and
remember here again we need to manage
the power the variability the most X you
have the more functionality but the more
performance limitation and that's it for
today thank you sure you need to
collaborate too much presumably you're
getting your own protocols on the chip
you're not you're trying to do anything
like protocols so that the physical
protocol is the handshake on the top of
it we have virtual channels which is a
classical NOC protocols to avoid
congestion and it's you see you here
it's architectural protocol not protocol
and in the bottom we have physical
protocol which is the unchic which is
replacing the country how much does the
device characteristics vary over the
temperature range during normal
operation for which for which devices in
the multi layer unit in the TSB say say
in the vision have an application do you
have I mean it seems like they're issues
thermal expansion of one layer there
firmly bound together than there strain
issues on device characteristics also
electrical timing yeah so the so the
bias stem cells they are more sensitive
to the alignment that we have during
fabrication but after fabrication we
have some thermal issues and it's
considered as variation that we need to
handle dynamically but as in a
transistor we have some PDT variation
that we need to handle then we add some
variations on the wire itself but it has
to be considering the full flow and in
the architecture and in the power
management structure you present to the
user his people so you talk about edge
computing can you be a little more
specific so you have maybe you don't
have right now but you have really a
more concrete target application at the
edge what do you think this makes sense
for any vices it's more clear for me
that it's sensing applications different
type of sensing at the end at the edge
multiple thing that could be image
sensor wake up RF so sensing the
channels that you have around to
communicate in Wireless it can be a
tactile depending on your application
it could be audio it can have many
different ways of sensing these devices
it's kind of like application specific
it's doing some you know things or
something
I think that the most interesting thing
we could provide is to provide a
contextual information with all the
sensors together
this is what we call multimodal
multimodal platforms meaning that ok you
see something but you just courage with
what you hear and here I know where I am
I'm not Atleti because I see you and I'm
not at home because I see you at all
don't hear my kids and all these
contextual information if you can bring
it ready at the edge or at the end
devices then the information you get
from a sensing platform is very
interesting but then you need a lot of
of of sensing of embedded learning many
things so usually you target one
application it's easier in terms of the
power instead of getting everything
budget for one end device I would say
when you talk about microwatt I like it
as you can educate yes and as now as
soon as you have a wireless
communication you need to start to MIDI
words or tens of minutes ok but if you
consider the edge edge maybe you don't
have you don't you know you're plugged
so maybe you don't need to have energy
harvesting or whatever
so then Mira watts is something that is
affordable for edge I would say and as
long as you have wireless communication
of course way I've tried to push
Wireless people to go down to micro but
they don't want you know I believe in
you know you guys had an idea on a
ferroelectric which you know seems like
it's going to be available in 20 to 30
years all right and so you didn't
mention that as one of your
I think it's more an extra memory that
we have I think it's the ox from that we
are trying to build on the top of its
kind of with the best reliability and
with everything so whatever is the
device we need to figure out how to use
it but in any case it's the question I
had for Alex at the end of this talk so
what will you do if you had non-volatile
resistive memories that are very good
and this we need to figure out because
of course the devices are not coming
always in one month or two month but
it's still interesting to to figure out
that architecture and design memo how do
you consider in any sort of error
detection in your asynchronous
communication in the course in the
course we have some error detection so
it's not error detection
it's anticipating errors because we have
this adaptive skin so we need to know
where we are in the critical paths with
respect to the slack to be sure that
when we are starting to get this margin
of the slack we really need to modify
the voltage and frequency because it
means that we are ready in the dangerous
zone so we are correlating the PVC
sensors with
these error detection which is what we
call timing for 10 so it's razors with
some methodology around but it's kind of
razors and then we are able to modify
the voltage and the frequency
accordingly of course it's really the
basis of a BFS systems with your
architecture you can kind of emulate
some biological sensors and things like
that but have you tried to emulate
hearing or sight or smell or anything
yet how fast can you do it no no really
here we are more really focusing on
simple circuits and system the fool I
would say the full application and how
the smells work and so on no we're not
working on that yet synchronous
communications so it's twice the latency
and twice in throughput compared to a
synchronous natural tension so you you
double the throughput and you double the
latency but then when you use it that's
what puts is just giving you yeah you
reduce under basic goodness transfers
per second I'll compare to what's first
a synchronous communication you mean if
you put too many things in parallel do
it synchronously it doesn't work because
you end up with power distribution
problems if you do two things too fast
asynchronously run into races yeah but
here we're not doing computation it's
communication it's a question so is it
the rate of the communication that
you're asking for really what you're
trying to arbitrate
[Music]
21 gig in and of course they are just
running at I don't know not one gigabit
around the cost of computing itself in
28 I give the number 28 ft sy let's say
your question is so your question is is
the communication limiting of the
computing performances yeah is the
communication limiting the performances
are the core limiting the performance is
right communication so the signals to G
can as fast as goes and there will be no
problem and knock-back given point but
at the limitation the protocol is very
easy and usually the clock is a limit so
actually we are not able to feed the
single pipe and as fast as we could so
we are just emitted by injecting
trafficking in that the signals logic
and
where we are synchronizing between both
the guides interfaces because you had
five foes and on the one side of the
five fights asynchronous on the other
side is synchronous so here calculations
and then you communicate you do more
calculations and then you communicate
your communication is so slow compared
to the calculations that you don't run
into them asynchronous
architecture then application
multiplication and communicate I think
we talked about it all the day today
[Laughter]
those speeds and that kind of
architecture I could give you algorithms
that would emulate recognizing objects
because you just get the rate but then
maybe when so I took with the egestion
in ski working on artificial retina so
what it says is now the limitation is
not ready the rate of the spike that you
can compute but really all the first
interface to the sensors gathering all
these spikes together so we are still
not yet improving in the same as part
they still have some recognize in a
second-order pure establish customer
base what is the time frame when do you
think commercial products might emerge
there are many different things in my
presentations on the architectural level
for gals and power management I think
it's on the market now because everybody
is doing a BFS gvfs and some people are
doing gals even if they are not using a
synchronous knock but more and more
people are doing trying to get to a
synchronous knock as well and for the
devices so 3d is a one part of 3ds
already is already fabricated so you can
have access if you want then for
sequential 3d the monolithic 3d it's not
mature yet but it depends on how
companies are pushing but things are
moving very fast less lightly so I would
say that I would expect that a first
maybe product in three to five years
could be something that is feasible it
depends of course on how things are
moving on the industrial side and for
relative memories there are already many
resistive memories available the thing
now is to have more dense memories being
able to have multi values in
sites or less variability may be stacked
in 3d to have more density and so on
so yeah there are different levels of
maturity of all this as soon as you are
using emerging devices it takes some
years of course to to get to the
maturity but for architecture it can go
really fast and on the market in new
products so how do u s-- 'fl work and
situated spikes like I can think in
terms of C compilers and organs figure
out what to do with spikes you're
figuring out what you have not you know
yeah what's the best way to program this
there are a lot of lot of discussions
around that so people are comparing
spiking your networks and artificial
neural networks in terms of programming
it's really different so there are some
programming tools already but it has not
shown a full interest I would say if now
you are going more to sensing and here
it's different because what we have is a
spike in DSP so the way to program it is
just to program the framework on the top
of it it means that for an additional or
multiplier we just program the DSP to
say ok for a multiplier you get these
neurons these synapses you assemble it
and you get and you run the operation so
there are ready different levels of
programming in your question so I would
say for snn people are working on
programming models but for already
sensor interfaces it's something
different so it's it's I think spiking
your networks are still under
discussions a lot because people do not
consider the distributed activity so
still when we are considering to get all
the information from a mass storage it's
still not interesting compared to a
classical neural network where you have
less memory available so yeah still
still under discussion a lot of forums
and so I don't have to be the answer to
this
from a perspective on the resistive
memories what's like the static current
look like on various three different
types of this the resistive memories not
yet if you mentioned three different
types yeah what is the static leakage
current look like I can give you some
papers but I don't have a clear figures
here to give you order of the leakage no
I don't have no ready I can give you
some figures with here I don't have no
it's very specific device question I
would designer now usually I know the
leakage of a transistor but not yet of
that kind of things there's there has so
many and the variability is very large
so probably they but I can give you the
figure of Oxfam which you want I have it
somewhere
[Applause]
you